So all the examples we've seen so far,
all of the elements in the list had the same type.
We had a list where all the elements were strings.
We had a list where all the elements were numbers.
There's no restriction on lists, though.
We can make all of the elements any type we want.
We can mix and match different things in 1 list,
so here's an example.
We've put some strings and some numbers together in 1 list.
That's perfectly okay.
Where it gets even more interesting is we can have a list inside a list.
Now one of the elements of "mixed up" is itself a list,
and we can have another list inside that.
Here we've defined a new variable, mixed up.
It contains a string, a number, a string, a number,
and then a list.
The fifth element is itself a list that contains
a number, a number, and contains another list.
This example shows the versatility of lists,
that we can put anything we want in them.
It doesn't seem particularly useful
because there's no structure to the things we've put in the list.
So let's try another example that may give a better idea
of why it's so useful to be able to have lists inside lists.
Before we defined the variable "beatles" as a list of 4 strings,
just the names of the Beatles.
Now we've defined the variable beatles as a list of lists
where each element of the list is a list
of the name of the person as well as the date when he was born.
We have the first element in our list as John,
who was born in 1940.
Let's see how that works in the Python interpreter.
When we start to have long lists, especially lists of lists like this,
they might not all fit on 1 line.
It's okay to divide things into 2 lines,
but we have to be a little careful where we do the division
to make it clear to the Python interpreter
that it's all part of 1 list.
The place where you want to do the separation is after a comma,
and if you indent things in a way that makes that clear,
then you can see the structure, that these 2 lines
are still part of the same list, and it's the closed bracket here
that closes the list.
Now let's try printing that out,
and we see the list containing 4 elements.
Each element itself is a list containing 2 elements.
We can print just 1 of the elements.
We'll print the element at position 3,
which is actually the fourth element of the list.
We see that element itself is a pair.
That's a list.
So if we want to get just the name from that, well,
then we need to use index again, so we can use index again
to get the 0 position element of that list,
and that will give us just the name.
If we used index 1 here,
that will give us the year.